there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey you guys it's Tuesday
once again and it's time for episode 120
now this one we actually did a creepy
disappearances show back on I think it
was episode 62 and I think I did four
cases on that one I think I did like
Maura Marie and Brian Schaeffer I think
I did you know like a couple of other
ones but I had gotten so many requests
for different like creepy disappearance
cases and stuff like that that I decided
it was about time to do another one yeah
with just kind of I was gonna do I have
like six or seven cases and I don't know
if I'm gonna get to all of them but I
definitely do want to get to most of the
ones that people have requested some of
them are kind of complicated yeah maybe
it's so we're just gonna see how we are
on time it's like if it starts kind of
going on I have a bunch of you know
notes prepared but if you know if it
starts bleeding over into like hour and
a half or something like that then I'll
probably just cut it short and maybe the
ones that are left over I'll do a whole
episode yes some of these
missing-persons cases actually kind of
bleed into the paranormal subjects like
Steve Mira did some investigations on a
missing on a missing person in England
and evidently that person went vanishing
vanished from the time they got out of
their car door to the bottom of the
steps of their apartment which like only
30 or 40 feet they don't know where that
person went never do that's pretty
creepy yeah they saw her get out and
then they never saw her reached the
apartment that might be the one case in
history where they she just slipped into
another dimension yeah yeah that's what
he was looking erratically that could
happen yeah if I remember correctly
really I remember correctly okay he was
telling about the case but it was a long
time ago no he never never could figure
it out yeah I talked to Steve the other
day Steve's doing good we got to have
Steve back on show I know we haven't had
mom for such a long time it's like I
don't even got to
you spent a lot of time in the US doing
little tours around it
he's flying the American flag outside
his house now anyway he's got an f-22
Raptor out there yeah he likes America
but yeah so the thing about creepy
disappearance is like I said you know as
fascinated as I am with unsolved murders
like I said I'm eventually hopefully one
of these days I kind of want to do a
trilogy of creepy disappearances too
because these are almost even more
frustrating because it's like not only
you know it's not like an unsolved
murder where it's like yeah the person
is dead you just don't know who did it
but these it's like they never even find
the person it's like where the hell did
they go it's like you don't even know if
they're dead if they change their
identity if they like loss their memory
who [ __ ] knows it's like you know and
particularly nowadays I think since
everybody is so connected you know
knowing social media and everything like
that it seems hard to believe that
someone could just like fall off the
face of the earth but evidently people
still do everyday and yeah it's pretty
weird well it's it's harder to disappear
nowadays and not be missed like thank
you really look at the dead history like
supposed to be back in the 70s or 80s if
you didn't have any loved ones that gave
a [ __ ] about you and you came up missing
they just forgot about you yeah cuz
people digital and I read a couple you
know I read about a couple of them like
when I was talking about like say the
highway of tears murders or santa
rosalia checkered murders you know the
you know all that kind of crap in the
stuff in Texas where like Texas killing
fields it's like some of the people
weren't reported missing just because
they were you know they were itinerant
they were just like traveling around the
country they didn't really have any
family or their family didn't really
care where they were a lot of these
cases they didn't know they were missed
until they find the dead body
yeah that is they had been killed like
decades ago and they need to know that
person was missing that's pretty creepy
you got to have family behind you
pushing for for your discovery you know
what happened to my daughter you know
sad to say it's like a lot of times when
people go missing it's really their
family that keeps it in the media
because there's so many people go
missing all the time it's like they
can't take a media attention too you
know cause it's like I said maybe what's
happen every day yeah and they got
people who had a catch they got ongoing
crimes right exactly so
you know as shitty as it is say they're
gonna be prioritised yeah they're just
not enough so you know like I said some
of these cases are still in the media
today particularly the case of Madeleine
McCann which I might or might not get to
that I don't know because that's a very
very complicated case it might need its
own episode but I'm not sure I might
actually have time to get to it we'll
see how it goes because that's there's
all kind of tendrils you know if you
look at some of these serial killer
cases if you look at it from the point
of view of the cops they're not looking
for a missing woman they're actually
thinking about entire groups of women we
think about 50 women who come up missing
in this area we think that's kind of
weird when you think about it that way
that the whole groups of people could
come up missing over time in a certain
area and the cops just start to get a
little bit suspicious we think about 50
women maybe missing from here more or
less that's weird
it's like what the Green River Killer
you know they knew people were missing
and they didn't find him on the banks
and sometimes they didn't know they were
missing until they were found on the
banks yeah some creepy [ __ ] like I said
especially if you ever have a like a
high-risk profession like a prostitute
or something like that it's like yeah Oh
chances of there being investigation go
down yeah like I said be careful out
there girl seriously all right but
before we get to that let's do are a
couple little shout outs um as I said
I'm still editing the audio for our
faceless villain - it's a little more
than halfway done so you know what I
mean so hopefully it won't be too much
longer before that's up also if you
didn't see our latest movie
retrospective it was the classic Blade
Runner so we finally got around to doing
that so go check that out if you haven't
already also if you haven't been to our
zazzle store lately I've been putting
our logo on all sorts of new products
yeah like I haven't done I still haven't
had time to do like the Keela shirt or
the wandering womb shirt a couple want
to be and also someone wanted me to do a
dick stealing shirt dick stealing which
I'm trying to figure out how to do that
and stay in fish like the public G
rating that should be a mission
impossible based theme like one of mr.
impossible posters you know cuz it'd be
an impossible mission to steal my dick
think I'm gonna let that go without a
fight
yeah but if somebody did it from far
away through which witchcraft would work
there's nothing you could do about it
you have to like put a salt ring around
yourself like in the gin were common
call back to the last week's show but
yeah so but what I did in the meantime
was I put like some of our logo designed
like our fancy logo and kind of just
with us in the clock and stuff and I put
that on a bunch of other press like you
know coasters mugs [ __ ] like that pillow
which I think came out very nice but I
do say so myself so you know follow the
little link down key the jar I do it's
like I did make and I'm gonna eventually
do a cool one I realized that dazzle has
mason jars that you can put stuff on and
I'm like oh my god we have to have a 13
o'clock mason jar yeah what kugel Khan
on it so I'm like I have a logo one
right now but eventually when I do the
key legit I'm also gonna do do a glass
specific logo Mexican where's their
mexican calendar on it yeah it's gonna
be maybe kids on there something we'll
have we'll figure it out
well yeah I'm gonna have to put cocoa
con on there because that's just kind of
that's the whole theme of your drinking
experience you know what I mean put you
on there dressed up like an Indian
[Laughter]
hilarious I'd be like the whitest yeah I
might be a cartoons cartoons of you yeah
so really like the Lana make cartoons
they're really just the boobs but yeah
so like I said check out her Rosella
store I'm gonna be adding more stuff you
know over the next months but I did just
add a bunch of new logo stuff other than
t-shirts so go have a look if you would
also I'd like to give a shout out to our
newest patron whose name is Liam hey
there that man thanks thank you very
much we really appreciate it and if you
you know you'd like to become a patron
you know there's all kinds of fun little
things you can get and obviously go to
our patreon page at 13 o'clock podcast
and I'll kind of say that at the end
again patrons are piling up
let's keep them rolling need to give
this up to about $1,000 a month that'd
be awesome
it really would be nice because I mean
especially because it would kind of free
me up to do more things with the show
and not be not be like contractually
obligated to keep doing graphic design
I'll make sure just picked up on all
fronts a graphic design is stealing a
lot of time but you can't turn the money
down that's the thing yeah that's what I
mean cuz that's usually like immediate
money so I usually have to do that
that's why it's taking me so long to do
the audio book to just because you know
I get up and I'm like oh I'm gonna work
on the audio book all day today and then
like I get like okay but yeah so that's
that's that alright so now the first
thing I wanted to do this is kind of
like a news story and also a creepy
disappearance because this like just
happened like a couple months ago and I
hadn't heard about it because I haven't
notice concen but somebody requested
this and I said well it's kind of a
short there's not a huge amount of
information about it because it you know
it's very recent but since someone
requested it I will include it on the
show is kind of like a little bonus news
story type of thing and this is the
disappearance of Jamie cloths she's 13
years old and this happened very
recently as I said October 15th and this
was in Barren Wisconsin apparently the
girl was at home with her parents in
they there was a 911 came in about one
o'clock in the morning the dispatcher
said that they couldn't hear anyone like
they didn't talk to anyone on the 9-1-1
call but they could hear like a
commotion in the background so you know
obviously the 911 you know the officers
responded to the scene because they
figured that something was wrong and so
then they get there they discover that
the door to the house has been kicked in
the parents of Jamie cloths whose names
are James and Denise are dead of gunshot
wounds and Jamie cloths is gone abducted
yes so evidently like I said this just
happened you know they the nine one one
dispatcher like I said they didn't talk
to anyone when they called back to
and see what was going on it's Denise's
deniz classes cellphone and it just went
right to voicemail so obviously
something bad had happened when they
were doing the investigation later on
neighbors said they had heard gunshots
around between 12:30 and 1:00 a.m. but
they didn't think anything of it this is
Wisconsin it's kind of a hunting area
like kind of rural so it's like you know
there's people out in the woods hunting
and shooting guns all the time so we
didn't think anything about it
so you know that kind of went nowhere
also there was still the family had a
dog evidently and the dog was still in
the house so that's about all they know
about it they said they've checked all
this surveillance footage like from you
know around the house I guess from
various businesses around the house or
whatever they have two cars that they
are looking for in relation to the case
they don't know if it has anything to do
with the case these were just cars that
were in the area one of them is a 2008
to 2014 Dodge Challenger either red or
orange the other one they're not sure
it's either a 2006 to 2010 Ford Edge
which is black or a 2004 to 2010 Acura
MDX so these are like two cars that
they're kind of looking for obviously
they've put out the Amber Alerts and
everything and they've been searching
for this little girl like I said she's
only 13 years old they've been searching
for since October 15th since she
disappeared bringing the family so far
have had no luck gotta be somebody who
knew him so friend of the family you
would think I mean you know and I said
they said they've gotten thousands of
tips but so far they haven't found
anything it's like you know they've had
the the dogs the sniffing dogs out you
know along the route where could have
been kind of a cyber stalker type
situation where it was a boyfriend of
the 15 year old girl she's 13 well 13
year old girl man she thought that the
guy she was talking to was her age or a
little bit older too turned out he might
have been you know in his late teens
early twenties enough to drive went down
and found out where she lived but he
sounds like somebody who knew the
interior of the house yeah I mean to
just kick in the door and just like
shoot the parents and I mean that seems
like a very calculating kind of reminds
me the Ferrell case member what's his
name the the vampire killer rod Ferrell
rod Ferrell where he was talking to the
girl long distance and the girl kind of
complained a lot about her parents
he decided to be the hero went down
there and kill her killer and haratz to
freer yes she could join his little
vampire cult
yeah well you know I worked for his
first lawyer yeah yeah that's right yeah
cuz we watched the documentary yeah yeah
she's yeah she was actually yeah used to
work at her at her barn right and her
law firm and in her life right yeah yeah
it did some maintenance work for and
also some like light clerical work for
for a while yeah and I saw his I saw his
Case Files not interesting though yeah
just yeah just paperwork huh paperwork
about dates and you know his name is
Kandice yeah that's that's the name yeah
like I said I remember we watched that
documentary it was probably just like a
few months ago we were watching the
documentary about it
met her through the family yeah my
mother trained your horse yeah yeah
that's how I met her yeah that's some
crazy [ __ ] so yeah this is like I said
this case is still very new it only
happened a couple months ago obviously
there's a very large reward and believe
it's $25,000 for any information so if
anybody knows anything
you know I guess called go to Baron
Wisconsin sheriff's office or what have
you and report any information if you do
know anything about it now the next case
I want to talk about was the
disappearance of Leah Roberts
this happened in March of 2000 she was
23 years old when she went missing which
means she'd be about 42 years old now
now here's what happened evidently Leah
Roberts um she was almost done with
college I think she was only like three
months shy of college now she had had
some kind of bad things happen her life
like her mother died unexpectedly which
upset her very much
her father had a long-standing illness
and he actually ended up dying and then
Leah herself was in a near-fatal car
accident and it took her like a really
long time to recover she had to have
like metal thing put in her leg and
everything like that so evidently
friends and family she had a sister
named Cara friends and family said that
one the death of her parents was
obviously very traumatic for her
and as was this accident but they said
after the accident she almost kind of
had I you know I don't want to sound
like new agey and stupid like a
spiritual reawakening but she like
learned to appreciate her life more and
according to her sister and friends she
kind of got into a thing where she
started reading a lot of Jack Kerouac
she started like you know hanging out in
coffee shop so you know writing a lot a
lot of poetry and stuff and kind of
getting more interested in kind of
getting back to the land or like you
know getting away from materialistic
lifestyle or whatever it was that she
was doing so what she evidently did was
that she decided she was gonna pack up
all her stuff and kind of followed the
trail of Jack Kerouac on his journey
that was in the book the Dharma bums
where he actually went to out to
Washington State and he took a job like
as a forest fire you know guy watches
for forest fires like up in the Cascade
Mountains or whatever and he like talked
about how beautiful the landscape was
and it was like a spiritual experience
and everything like that so what
evidently she wanted to do the same
thing so she actually like I said she
was only about three months shy of
graduating from college but she dropped
out of college
she had an inheritance from the death of
her parents
I believe her sister also had access to
the same accounts they had like you know
similar inherence and Cara could check
on the you know on her withdrawals and
whatnot um she packed up all her stuff
she packed up she had a little kitten
named B and she also packed up her a
little kitten there a little cat carrier
took cat food and everything like that
and apparently took off and she didn't
tell anybody where she was going but
after they found out like where you know
that she was gone like her sister goes
to the her apartment she says there's a
note there and leah has left a note that
said I'm not suicidal quite the opposite
she's like remember Jack Kerouac so then
her sister is like oh well she must be
going out to Washington State so she
starts checking into the account and she
sees that she's correct that leah has
driven across the country she started
out in North Carolina I believe and
drove three days across the country like
to Oregon they showed her taking a
little cash out to buy gas
not and evidently that was about as far
as she went now March 1st I believe it
was March 1st 2000 there's two people
jogging in Washington State on Mount
Baker and they see like a little piece
of clothing like hanging from a tree
branch and they look down in the ravine
and there's an SUV down there that's
gone off the embankment so they don't
see anyone around the car there's I mean
obviously it's wrecked but there's no
blood there doesn't seem to be anyone
around they're inside the car they find
the passport they find Lea Roberts ID
they find a large amount of cash I
believe is about $2,500 they find some
cat food a cat carrier but they find no
Lea and no cat so the weird thing though
is that the car even though I mean when
the police came to investigate they're
like the car looks like it was going
about 40 miles an hour when it went off
the embankment okay the windows were
broken and everything like that
they're like if somebody had been in
this car they would have been you know
injured horribly injured they said so
there was no blood around there was no
blood in the car there was no blood
around the car and they brought in the
dogs and everything and it's like we
couldn't find any sign that any Ben had
been wounded in this car it was staged
that's what people are thinking they
said because an interesting thing too is
that when they found the car because all
the windows were busted out and
everything like that but there were like
blankets like hanging up on the inside
as though someone had taken shelter in
there so they don't know if that was her
they don't know if she they said they
didn't really find evidence that she had
started the car and like pushed it off
the embankment or if she had gone toward
the embankment then jumped out they said
it was going 40 miles an hour so she
probably would have hurt herself if she
jumped out but they didn't find any
evidence of that either could she have
gotten out of the car for some reason
and then accidentally left the car
neutral mid rolled off the street
possible but would it roll at 40 miles
an hour I mean 30
five forty is kind of slow really yeah
you think maybe she got out of the car
for some reason or another and left it
in neutral yeah it started rolling
backwards it's just a rule or road
forward or something and then it went
off the embankment
and then she crawled down there to see
what she could get out of the car maybe
the cat yeah cuz they didn't find any
sign of the cat anywhere yeah cat got
out maybe she let the cat out cat got
out for some reason or another she got
lost down there
although maybe I'm getting ahead of
myself there maybe there's more well
yeah but here's the weird thing so the
cops like the sheriff that investigated
it he says okay there so they obviously
they took the SUV and they you know
towed it to the police garage and went
over it yeah they said they found like I
said twenty-five hundred dollars which
was stashed into her like a her pants
pocket they also found something that
Leah's friends and family said that she
would never leave behind and that was
Leah's mother's engagement ring
now after Leah's mother had died Leah
took the engagement is like a keepsake
of her mother and her friends and family
said she never took it off so they found
this wedding ring it was like under I
think it was under one of the floor mats
or like on one of the floor mats like on
the floor of the thing and they're like
she never would have willingly left that
behind so they don't know if she was an
accent maybe she lost her memory or
something like that but like I said it
if she was in the car when it crashed
you think they would find blood or they
would find evidence of that and they
haven't found any evidence that she was
in the car when it crashed you know what
I mean doesn't mean she wasn't in the
car no I know
but I'm just saying they just thought it
was odd that there was no blood no hair
no nothing like that it just seemed very
weird that that would have happened and
like I said they know that when she left
initially when she left her apartment in
North Carolina she did do that on
purpose and they knew that she Drew was
driving across the country and they knew
pretty much where she was going she was
going to the jack kerouac place in the
Cascade Mountains because she wanted to
do the same thing as her hero now how
far down was was was the actually I
don't know I'd like to actually see a
photograph yeah it would be interesting
but yeah it's just it's just this whole
thing is just like so weird now her
sister insists
she's like look something bad must have
happened to her because you know all the
[ __ ] that our family has been through
like all our parents dying and stuff
like that she would never let us go
through loss again like that and not
tell us where she was unless somebody
killed her or unless she lost her memory
or unless something else bad happened
the memory loss thing I never really buy
that I think the memory kind of comes
back or they find the person disorient
didn't they figure out who that person
is now there is with one last little
detail in this case and I'm not sure if
this is you know if this is anything or
not but about a week after they found
Leah's car in this ravine this guy
anonymously called police and gave him a
tip and said hey my wife saw a woman
that looked like Leah and she was at a
gas station about 30 miles from Seattle
and she looked disoriented and confused
that's what but I don't like I said I
don't know and the guy would not give
his name or his wife's name or anything
they asked him for his information and
he just hung up so I don't know so you
know I don't know how seriously to take
how long had that car been down there
like she'd been missing for how long not
long because um it was only a day or two
because they knew that she had bought
gas at this particular gas station like
only a day or two before the car was
found I'd like to see how far down the
embankment this car was ya know what is
what if she did run the car off the off
the road and got hurt but didn't break
any skin yeah so she wasn't bleeding but
broke some bones she let the cat out all
right and then she tried to crawl out of
the the car couldn't crawl up the
embankment she was too busted up so she
crawled down instead something then
later on a few days later maybe died of
dehydration or Ares then the animals got
the body and the cat was never to be
found
yes I'm like that really this could have
gone this could go either way I mean it
could be a case where she picked up
someone and they turned out to be a
serial killer who knows and they like to
crash the car and then they took her
somewhere it's yes see a single woman
picking up a guy that's what I mean they
usually don't but you know what I mean
you never know I mean she might not have
just picked him up but she might have
just met him somewhere and he
nice and he's like you know she knew him
for a day or two and they just like he's
like hey I need a ride so maybe she got
into a pissing match on the road with
somebody here in he or she drove her off
the road yeah see there's like a million
possibilities and then she got hurt you
know I went down there and got her it's
like she could have staged it although
like I said her family was like why the
hell would she do that it's like why
would she put us through that like after
everything the family been through that
was unlikely yeah that would be really
like an [ __ ] move so I don't know the
police are kind of I don't think they're
they're not doing it as a murder
investigation because they don't think
anybody murdered her but they do think
there was some kind of weird there like
it's possible obviously but at the
moment they're just kind of looking at
it as an accident but they don't know
she's alive somewhere and like I said
they did the grid search they did the
dogs and everything here's this again mm
it's a long time ago
yeah it was a long time ago but yes this
one creeped me out because it's just
like that [ __ ] car at the bottom of
the ravine and that's all day and she
had obviously been or someone had been
like sleeping in there maybe I mean I
would assume cuz they put blankets
everything she may have been sleeping in
there for a while yeah I mean like I
said I think it'd only been a day or two
she had to go for help yeah for some
reason couldn't get up the ravine yeah I
think it was some type of an accident
she couldn't get the ravine she had to
me broken leg to me broken limbs yeah
went down for some reason then died then
the body washed away or the animals got
it yeah I wonder because yeah it's you
know this is kind of like a remote area
like up in the Cascade Mountains and
stuff all kind of animals up there I
don't know if it was close to like a
river yeah
or anything maybe she crawled to a river
and then she died of exposure and then
got washed away it's like maybe the cat
stayed with her for a while when she
died or was she crawled off the cat just
you know cat dog to cat cat does what a
cat does yeah just like well she's dead
I gotta go yeah I gotta go find
something yeah it was an accident I'm
kind of leaning toward that too it's
like yes it's possible it could have
been foul play cuz listen I've written
about some unsolved murders and some
fucked-up [ __ ] happens out there you
guys but like this to me does not seem
like I mean
it's bad enough that they didn't find
any evidence of her in the car they for
sure didn't find an evidence at anybody
else hard to get somebody out of it was
too hard to get a woman out of it out of
a running car I mean it's hard yeah you
know unless you run that woman off the
road yeah and you do that you could bust
her up and kill her and not be able to
do anything with her yeah you know
chances are she ran the car off the road
fell asleep behind the wheel something
like that yeah she wasn't moved going
very fast and then she got badly hurt
couldn't get back up to the road yeah
that's what I think happened yes sir I
think it's more likely it's you know
it's impossible to know baby that's more
likely that she cuz we're job of the
road it does seem yeah Godley's probably
got injured and then she stayed in that
car for a while and she was like oh
they're not gonna see me down in here I
gotta get out of here yeah and she
didn't make it she died on her way maybe
she was trying to get up good and when
she died the animals came and got the
body yeah something like that
possible yeah so there's that one and
let's see this next one was actually
this was actually on unsolved mysteries
this room 1993 and someone requested
this one as well somebody actually
requested this one because it was a
military guy and they thought that you'd
be interested in it because it's there's
all kind of a conspiracy [ __ ] with this
one too this is the case of Justin Berg
winkle now like I said this happened in
1993 he was in the US Army he was
actually training to be a ranger and he
was like a language specialist this was
93 during the time I was in yeah it's
gonna say at the same time you're ready
so I know the exact army they're talking
about yeah you're training to be a
ranger okay and he was a language
specialist his specialty was Korean okay
he'd been in for three years but the
weird thing is like right like right
after he'd been in for three years he
suddenly went AWOL and now nobody knows
where he is three months after his
disappearance they found his car it was
in the parking lot of like a beachside
motel the cars the the car keys were
locked inside the car along with his
wallet his credit cards and his military
ID
now the person that they've talked to
the most about this he had a girlfriend
named Yolanda and well no because she
said that before he disappeared he was
acting like super super weird okay so
check this out now Justin's he was his
first he was first stationed at Fort Ord
which is in Monterey California
and that's when he met his girlfriend
Yolanda she was a college student at
Santa Clara University studying computer
science
what rank is he did did you he I don't
know sounds like an officer yeah I don't
know okay I don't think it's best or I
didn't see in this write-up but didn't
see what it's best fine
okay but so you know he him and her like
kind of got together and he would like
when he had leave he would drive down to
see her and blah blah blah now she said
that after a little while she started
seeing that he was acting like really
weird like they would be hanging out and
then suddenly he'd be like I have to go
back to Monterey and see some people but
I'll be right back
like we just suddenly like out of the
blue and she'd be like okay what's that
about and then she would ask him so
what's going on like is there he's and
he would say stuff like I can't tell you
it's a secret like I'm involved in like
secret [ __ ] right and she's like okay so
she thought that was a little strange
and he was actually like kind of weird
and paranoid so he'd been at Fort Ord
for about three years and then he got
transferred to Fort Lewis which is in
Washington State and then he didn't see
you longer for about two months cuz he
didn't have any leave so then he got a
two-week leave and he came down to see
her and she said when he came down to
see her then she said he always had like
this briefcase right and she's like he
would never let me look in it like he
was like super secret like I can't tell
you what's in here it's and he would
never open it like in front of her and
stuff so it's like one time she tried to
kind of like look and see what was in
there cuz she was really curious because
he was acting so weird she's like so one
time I look over my shoulder and all
that he's doing is like he's pulling
pieces of paper out of this briefcase
and like tearing them in little pieces
that's like all he was doing right so
the and then Yolanda says you know up to
his disappearance just weird shits arms
she's like she walks into the live
one day and he's like sitting there
crying later she gets a phone call at
her apartment and she picks it up and
she says the guy on the other end says
to her the missions off and she says
what does that mean and he says just
tell Justin that the missions off and
then she told Justin this and he flipped
out like he was like what the [ __ ] I
don't like he was all mad about it so
then he starts buying all these guns he
starts buying all this ammunition and
then he doesn't show up back at Fort
Lewis so then they consider that he has
gone AWOL um he actually after he went
AWOL he did show up at Yolanda's
apartment and she told him why don't she
go back to base you're supposed to be
you know aren't you gonna get in trouble
and he evidently did call Fort Lewis and
say yeah I'm gonna come back but then he
didn't you know what I mean
so when Yolanda asked me she's like look
what the [ __ ] is going on all he would
tell her was that he's like watch the
movie white sands which is apparently
some kind of suspense movie and it's
about international arms smuggling so I
don't know if he was involved in
something like that or if I'm I'm
thinking that maybe he had schizophrenic
break
perhaps no think so maybe I don't know
that's kind of what I'm leaning towards
war I think he was involved in some kind
of some kind of drug ring it might have
been yeah yeah you know CID was always
trying to sniff out two drug rings and
prostitution rings yes you wouldn't
believe that there was prostitution
rings in the army but there were there
were why wouldn't I believe no I'm just
I never thought of that oh you know me
but some of those girls in the army got
mixed up in prostitution rings there's a
lot of money to be made and CID was
always trying to sniff him out a lot of
problems with [ __ ] like that and there
were weird drug rings in the service
they weren't super common you know I
mean but they did exist and what was
weird is it would be stuff you wouldn't
expect like guys selling steroids things
like that
it's a performance-enhancing drug right
yeah gotcha
and there was demands and I never really
have
proof I know got service guys steroids
we're not we're not popular in the
infantry but I noticed a lot of those
Special Forces guys looked kind of
[ __ ] big and made me wonder you know
I mean it's some of those special
operation guys because he end up with
dudes like Jesse the body and then he
ends up being a wrestler and you know
and a lot of body builders were into
that you know it would seem like a
pretty obvious yeah it always made me it
always made me wonder you know looking
back on it had you got involved in
performance-enhancing drugs you would
have gotten bigger alright and stronger
faster maybe you would have been
selected for some of those you know
talking about some of those Special
Forces units yeah but I didn't think
about it you know I guess I was kind of
naive some of those guys that I knew
that had special that were in Special
Forces well once they go to Special
Forces once they make it do selection
and q you never see them again they just
say goodbye come back they graduate say
bye guys I made it oh great and then
they're gone they're off in the seventh
group or fifth group they they were kind
of they were big dudes you know I told
you no not the size wise but just you
know they were brawny yeah they may have
been doing some of that that yeah that
very well may be the case yeah it's just
I don't know it seems very creepy to me
that he had this but because it should
be said okay so after you know what a
drug deal went went down and and maybe
they want maybe he was in a lot of debt
maybe he had screwed over some people
for some you know behind money and they
killed him possibly or he went on the
run because like I said they found like
he leaves his girlfriend's apartment
like I said he said he called Fort Lewis
and said yeah I'm coming back but he
never did come back and he left his
girlfriend's apartment and then no one
knows what happened to him after that
now like I said three months after he
disappeared they found his car and it
was in the parking lot of this Motel now
he had not checked into this Motel if
his name wasn't in the register or
anything like that
they didn't find any of his guns with
ammo that he had bought but the
briefcase that he had been so secretive
about was in the trunk in
the briefcase was his wallet inside the
wallet
were his dog tags it was it which they
thought was a little weird - so where
did this dude go I don't as far as I
know I don't think that they've ever I
don't think there's ever been any
activity like all this schizophrenic
activity or you know behavior you're
talking about to me this sounds like
meth sounds like methamphetamine could
have been that - which I never saw any
in any of it in the army but you know
that could that could be useful - I mean
a lot of people don't realize that
methamphetamine was is issued to certain
kind of troops issued to fighter pilots
sometimes for long missions well it was
World War two it wasn't even a secret
back then cuz like I've seen movies and
you call them fat pills
yeah from back in that day and they're
like they're not addictive that pills
you'll feel you'll have you'll have more
energy yeah they used to give them to
[ __ ] waffen-ss troops you know out
there on the Eastern Front they just
fight for [ __ ] weeks and months you
know yeah without even sleeping you know
but it didn't matter you know if off an
SS soldier didn't have a long life
expectancy anyway you know on the
Eastern Front they were dead within
months you know actually most of those
diet guys went down they fought to the
very end they went down with the Third
Reich they didn't survive it most of
them yeah take all the meth you need for
the right yeah yeah so this guy like I
said this this disappearance I had never
heard of it but apparently was on
unsolved mysteries back in the day and
someone requested that we look into this
and they said you probably find it
particularly interesting because he was
in the army about the same time as you
were yeah but yeah he was like super
like I said super see I think it was a
drug ring maybe it might have been yeah
you know what I mean and apparently I
mean he wasn't completely crazy because
Yolanda his girlfriend said that there
was a phone call that came in and said
the word the guy said the missions
office just sounded like hell just in
the midst of missions off he's
rationalizing he's acting crazy and
bragging to his girlfriend but he's
doing something like selling meth yeah
are steroids and taking math yeah weird
and then like you said he either
[ __ ] over somebody and they killed him
or he ran or he knew he was gonna get in
trouble and he took off somewhere
although like I said I don't think
there's been any that's a long time to
be missing yeah I don't think there's
been any they're not looking for him
where he changed his identity something
like that yeah I mean it was 93 I guess
that was kind of easier to do back then
yeah you know they probably killed him
that's what I'm thinking usually when
somebody's missing that long I mean you
just really have to think they're
probably and if you're if your business
partners are soldiers they're making
money in the army and they're afraid of
getting in trouble in the army and
losing their careers they're already had
the mindset of you know killing people
you probably killed him yeah you know oh
yeah probably like I said most of these
people the longer it goes on the more
likely it is that they're dead because
like you said I don't know you know how
accurate the whole oh I lost my memory
and I only just remembered things like
that I think that's very
it probably could happen but I think
it's very rare to rare and I think it's
temporary
yeah I think eventually it would wear
off I think that you know either the
person is dead or they're being kept
captive by somebody like that [ __ ]
Castro dude did to those poor girls back
then like where they were still alive
but they were just like chained in
somebody's [ __ ] basement yeah he got
his for [ __ ] how long was it 10 years
20 years a bitchin chaining up a woman
for nearly ten years and then when it
was his time to go incarcerate he
couldn't handle it
he oh I can't take this aren't they all
like that oh I can't take this you know
meaning I think that's well that's why
because they're weak and they know
they're weak so they have to like pick
on yeah he was smallest being captain
conditions better than he was kid
keeping those girls in right that's what
I mean it's like you had you put those
girls through that [ __ ] and now you're
crying about [ __ ] Jesus Christ he
castrum Castro was a hub he got treated
better than like they then he treated
them like you said he was like I said oh
those types of guys are like that though
yeah it's like they they'll inflict it
on other people they can take a dish now
they can't take exactly all right so we
got about to the halfway point of the
show I got a couple more cases I want to
talk about so we'll do that after the
break and we will be back in just a few
minutes with even more creepy
appearances
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay everybody Ginny's got some new
shirts designs up four of them really
good ones to Atlanta Ripper who put
Bella in the wit out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job
bottom where they found making Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out right yeah it
really good they're very high quality
shirts Jenny and I we're sure our own
shirts at certain times when we're
trying to put a spotlight on ourselves
and you can put a spotlight on
yourselves if you go ahead and pick up
on these shirts today you guys are gonna
love them links in the description WWL
comm at 13 o'clock yes oh go check out
our store at wwl com / 13 o'clock we got
these four cool new t-shirt designs plus
all our old ones if you'd rather get one
of the old ones but these ones are
awesome and you should check them out
they're also available in women's cut
they look really cute JD's got some so
thank you go check them out
okay we're back talking about more
creepy disappearances now over the break
I kind of looked at all my notes and
stuff like that and I think what I'm
gonna do with this episode is I think
I'm gonna talk about two more cases that
I had notes for like I said on this
episode I was gonna do the Madeleine
McCann case which probably the most
widely known missing-persons case in the
world but I think I'm gonna give that
its own episode because the more I
researched it today I'm like this prompt
probably deeds like a whole hour and a
half to talk about just because there's
so many little tendrils of it and
there's just so much of it going on and
it's still kind of ongoing even though
it happened a while back so I think I'll
do Madeleine McCann on another episode
and give so and give it more more breath
you know what I mean because I feel like
I can't really summarize it all that
well on one with a bunch of other people
on it I was actually gonna do like when
I first started thinking about this show
I was actually gonna do the
disappearance of the Jameson family
because this always chruch me out it's
like this whole family like this couple
and their kid and they vanished and like
they found their pickup truck and like
they're starving dog was in there there
was like $25,000 in cash in the truck
and all this other kind of stuff and
they couldn't find them but then I
discovered that they actually did find
their bodies the skeletons rather in
2013 although they still don't know
exactly what happened to them
so I maybe I'll do them on like an
unsolved murder show but I figured well
I'll take them off because it's not
technically a disappearance because they
did find their bodies many years later
just what you said right there that
sound like homicide well yeah they're
operating under that assumption sure
kind of weird that there was so much
cash in the car that was they don't know
what the hell was going on with that so
the motive was murder not that yeah so
that case always kind of creeped me out
and like I said I was gonna do it on
here but since it's technically not a
disappearance all do that on like an
unsolved maybe I'll give that its own
episode to you because I always found
that case really fascinating but let's
do a couple more missing-persons cases
now here's another guy this happened
fairly recently this happened in 2013
this guy's name is Brandon Lawson and
what some of the things that creeped me
out the most about some of these
missing-persons cases is like when
there's really
weird 9-1-1 calls because remember we
did that one I can't remember
um which case it was but we're the one
guy was like he he was like thought he
was at one place in this car he's like
oh I'm kind of lost and he was talking
on the phone to his dad I think and then
like all of a sudden you hear oh [ __ ]
and then it cuts off yeah and then they
never found him you know what I mean so
when ones we're like creepy
disappearance cases where there's like a
weird 911 call and then they never see
the dude again that like that creeps me
out a lot so this has that aspect to it
which is why I wanted to include it so
yeah this is Brandon Lawson so it's
happened in August of 2013 and this
happened in Texas now evidently him and
his girlfriend whose name is 'la daesil
often they've been together for like ten
years they were high school sweethearts
blah blah blah they had three kids
together and also he had another kid and
she was like the stepmom now they had
had a fight um she said it was pretty
bad fight evidently he had been a drug
addict but had gotten over it but hehe
had relapsed recently so she had kind of
you know taken him to task about that
and he got very upset and he left the
house now evidently he was going to his
parents house which was about three
hours away now on the way there
apparently his he had an f-150 and it
ran out of gas so he called his brother
at about 12:30 a.m. and he said hey can
you bring me some gas I ran into gas I'm
on US Highway 277 now he also said
something really weird according to his
brother he evidently said something like
three the the article says three
expletives so I don't I was like three
[ __ ] three you know bastards
three I don't know three something or
others are chasing me out of town so
then his brother Kyle says what are you
talking about and then Brandon says the
Mexicans in the neighborhood yeah
at which point Kyle is like are you high
because like I said he had been a drug
addict and that was the thing that he
had fought with his girlfriend about
was you know him relapsing on drugs and
he's like no no I'm you know I'm totally
you know I'm totally sober or whatever
so Kyle goes over to UM Ledesma and
Brandon's house to get the gas can now
he said I couldn't buy gas right then
because my paycheck hadn't gone into my
account yet so I didn't had any money in
there so he's like I figured what I
would do he's like I knew where Brandon
said his truck was so I'd figure I would
drive up there and bring him the gas can
and then you know maybe my money would
go in or we would figure out or I could
use his thing we could drive somewhere
and get some gas for the truck so he
goes - so he goes to where the truck is
now they don't find Brandon there
although at some stage brandon has
called 9-1-1 now I believe you can hear
the phone call on YouTube um you know
I've seen I've seen it in several places
because actually quite famous case um
you can't really tell exactly what
they're saying but some people have
tried to do like transcripts trying to
figure out what they're saying
so Brandon apparently says something
about I'm in the middle of a field and
then he says something like we're safe
we're just pushing guys over or
something like that we're out here going
towards Abilene on both sides my truck
ran out of gas
there's one car here then he says a
guy's something something to the woods
then he says please hurry then the
operator says run run that by me one
more time I didn't really get that and
then Brandon says something that sounds
like they will not talk things over I
accidentally ran into them then the
operator says okay you ran into them and
then it sounds like Brandon says shot
the first guy and then something that
sounds like gunshots in the background
the operator says do you need an
ambulance and then Brandon says yeah
no I need the cops and then the 9 1 1
office says is anybody hurt and then all
you hear is Brandon whispering something
that sounds like crap and then that's
the end of the phone call now at some
stage he said like
when his brother came and found the
truck because he did find the truck he
left the gas can in the back of his
brother's truck and then he was talking
on the phone to his brother and his
brother says I mean I can see you I'm in
a field I'm bleeding right so he didn't
say he'd been shot he didn't say if he
fell and that's why he was bleeding but
he said he could see his brother but his
brother couldn't see him and they're
like looking all around so there's all
kind of like [ __ ] phone calls they
have like all these timelines of phone
calls and [ __ ] like that okay so this
case is particularly mysterious because
one the dude's truck was out of gas just
like he said it was they have all the
9-1-1 calls they have all the phone
records they have the text messages
between him and his girlfriend but they
haven't they found no evidence of foul
play they went over the whole area in
helicopters their thermal imaging
cameras the whole nine yards and have
found nothing if the sheriff has even
said no leads no nothing they said the
only thing they can think of that might
have happened was that maybe he was in
trouble with somebody and somebody came
and picked him up in another vehicle
because I said we sure as [ __ ] couldn't
find him like anywhere around there and
they did look like I said so you know
the tire tracks nothing out in that
field no no like nothing at all unusual
like I said the sheriff just seemed like
when they took because I read like a
couple news stories about this and the
sheriff just seemed like totally
befuddled
he must have faked his own appearance
maybe I mean now his girlfriend said he
would never do that like he loved his
kids he wouldn't just leave us you know
but you never know I mean you never know
what's going on inside only two hours
she got attacked abducted vices some
kind of Mexican drug cartel like ms-13
you know which some people have
speculated that maybe he got kidnapped
by a drug cartel but there would have
been evidence that evidence left behind
like I said there was really no evidence
of that or he faked his disappearance
yeah now there was kind of a thing there
was some [ __ ] circulating about oh well
he had tried to cash in or he was in the
process of cashing in a 401k but his
girlfriend knew about that she's like
yeah he was in the process of doing that
but don't think the money had you know
gone it because I
cashed in a 401k it takes a really
really long time to get the money so you
know it's like really convoluted process
so I don't know if that had anything to
do because I think some people have like
pointed that it's like oh he was like
trying to get a big wad of cash so he
could like escape but I don't know if
that's the case like I said he had a
drug history and his girlfriend had got
mad at him because he had fallen off the
wagon recently essentially but I don't
know how involved he was like I don't
know if he ran afoul of some drug
dealers you know much like the last case
of Justin Bert Winkle maybe and maybe he
just decided to take off maybe he
thought his family was in danger there
could be like a lot of things but it
doesn't appear that I mean I don't even
really think they're approaching this is
a murder investigation because there was
just no they said they didn't find any
blood they didn't they didn't find a
body they did find any evidence of
violence in the area despite the 911
calls sounding like something bad was
happening there weren't any bullet holes
inside of his vehicle no blood nothing
nope
just taken out of there yeah disappeared
from that so they're like that's about
did you say he hit another car he said
we'll see like I said the 911 call is
very garbled okay and so I'm not sure
like what I read to you was like one
person's like transcription there's no
there was no evidence that the car was
in her in an accident no so I don't
there was no evidence that there have
been other people in that area of
footprints and not that I've ever heard
of that's what makes it so weird it's
just like because you faked it that's
what I mean it's like why why would you
call him like he just said all these
really weird things like over the phone
like I said it's very garbled so I'm not
sure if that's exactly what he said but
he was saying something like did he
really say he shot the first guy or
somebody shot him or I don't know but
they didn't like find any blood or
anything like that I wouldn't think it
would be any kind of an American crime
gang because it would have leaked out by
now probably it would be more likely
that some kind of a foreign he said
Mexicans from the neighborhood is he
talking about him ms-13 a Mexican drug
cartel I mean that John's brother said
that he said on the phone because I'm
good
he called his brother first and said hey
can you bring me some gas I ran out of
gas on us to 77 because if the guys who
did it went back
another country like Mexico you know I
mean the chances of it being ratted out
in exchange for a lighter sentence on a
related crime of course go down because
you're in the Mexican system right yeah
usually a lot of these weird murders are
solved because one of the guys involved
in it gets a small drug crime charge or
gets a robbery and gives it up look I'll
tell you what you know if you give me a
break I'll tell you about a murder that
happened five years ago that I was
involved in yeah you know that kind of
thing which to me it's like yeah it's
good like you'd never get information
otherwise I guess on some cases but how
seriously can you take that because it
is somebody trying to get something out
of it you know in a very serious cuz
they can name the names give the places
and it the cops are like oh yeah we
remember we got records that that
happened in yeah you know there man cuz
then you guys were there you know oh
yeah it wasn't me I didn't do he did it
I saw him do it you'll testify that you
saw him do it oh yeah yeah and you know
and mark and Robert know all about it
yeah it's good it's that's how it comes
out like I said just cuz I've written
about so many cases where like some
jailhouse snitch is like yeah I totally
know the dude that did that it's like
you know unless there's other proof I
don't think he can take it well it's
usually you know somebody trying to get
something out of it yeah but that's
usually not what's happening it's one
guy it's one guy saying he knows what
four or five other guys did yeah they
get a hold all those guys and they all
start giving signs it yeah yeah but I
didn't do it
yeah I mean it's that kind of stuff then
they figure out out of that crowd which
one was the most responsible they try to
lock a ball up that's what they do they
lock on every one of them up yeah yeah
it's kind of sad because I was like but
on this particular case I was reading
about
I mean his girlfriend lanessa was like
talking about she's like oh I really
wish I could take back all the mean
things I said about him that I because
he's gone now and it's you know it's
really that's really horrible and then
another thing she said too is that their
kids like have heard the 9-1-1 call on
youtube and it's like they're trying to
figure out like what their dad is saying
and stuff like that i'm like oh my god
that's awful
but the thing is it's like his family
didn't think that he would just take off
like that is his dad particularly was
like you know on the following monday
like you know what would have been the
following monday after his disappearance
he was due to start a new job which had
like a lot higher pay like better
benefit stuff like that so it's like
had career plans and stuff so well no
one knows what happens right no one
knows what happened but I'll tell you
this it's it's more likely that he faked
his death or faked an abduction that's
very likely there the family saying no
no no but but like I said do you ever
really know yeah you know exactly I know
that's a terrible depressing thing to
say but it's true you don't know what's
going on in somebody else's head you
just don't had this been a crime where
he was killed and everything by now
something would have surfaced I think
yeah and there'd have been Allah
evidence left behind there have been
more of a motive it's usually never
anything real cloudy or nebulous it's
usually not what happens somebody kills
somebody you know exactly why it
happened you know who did it yeah it's
something usually something real obvious
you know not most of the case is that
right about yeah well the motive and
that is always sex a lot of times you
know I just come by and thought hey I'll
kill her why not right and there isn't
any direct connection but when you're
killing a guy for organized crime type
reasons there's always a connection this
is why and this is very interesting
because I think when I was doing the
conspiratorial show Adam Sain asked me
about that he's like he's like what the
hell is the matter with dudes like just
killing these random chicks and
everything like that and I said I didn't
mean for my books that faceless villain
to just be like a cavalcade because
there are a lot of male victims in there
too I said I didn't mean for it to be a
cavalcade of you know random women
victims but the because I was kind of
leaving out you know robbery related
murders or gang related murders you know
I was doing like creepy unsolved writers
and a lot of cases I know this is
terrible to say but a lot of times when
a dude is murdered why do you know why
you know why there was a reason right um
so with women it's almost always a
sexual motive which it's very nebulous
you don't know who did it and like I
said when it's a random murder which is
what I was mostly focusing on when it's
a random murder the victim is usually a
woman because it's usually it's a woman
and walking home from the bus dude
Caesar he goes she's got a nice ass I'm
have a killer right really that's how
pretty much how it goes yep I mean like
I said there are some male victims in my
book and I did kind of put a few robbery
a few gay or like a few assassination
ones in there too just so I could have
some variety but the majority of the
cases in there are female victims and
that's why just because there was no
motive it was just like some woman
walking home from a bus walking home
from work
the motive was ass right that's pretty
much it that's a [ __ ] crazy ass
motive so like that's what I told him I
was like I don't know if that's a
controversial thing to say or not but I
said usually when a guy gets murdered
there's you know you know what you know
why but so yeah so that's why all right
so the last case I want to talk about
cuz like I said I'm gonna um I'll do the
Madeleine McCann one on its own show
because that's just that's too involved
to get into it with this it's late in
the show but I want to do the case of
Brianna Maitland because this is usually
linked with the very very famous Maura
Murray disappearance which I actually
discussed on episode 62 that was one of
the cases I talked about on there um
they don't think they're related
necessarily but they happened like in
fairly close proximity to one another it
was only about 90 miles apart and the
the situation by which it occurred was
actually quite similar so Brianna
Maitland she was actually born in 1986
now she went to it was her 17th birthday
this was in October of 2003 and she had
grown up in a real rural like farm and
Vermont and she decided in our 17th
birthday she's like you know I'm gonna
you know I have friends that live like
15 miles away I'm kind of sick of living
way out here in the middle of nowhere
so I'm gonna transfer to school and go
live with friends okay so her parents
said you know it was totally fine she's
like there was no discord going on in
the home or anything like that she just
wanted to get the hell out of there
because it was so rural she wanted to be
close to her friends they said okay fair
enough so she enrolled in a high school
about 15 miles away from her house and
kind of bounced around from friend's
house to friend's house like staying
with friends why not so she did drive
eventually drop out of high school but
she went back later and got her GED now
there was kind of an incident three
weeks before she went missing she was at
this party and a friend of hers whose
name was Kelly lacrosse like started
beating her up so they thought it was
some kind of altercation about a dude
that's what it usually is when girls
fight but the girl apparently [ __ ] her
up like apparently um Breanna was in her
truck like she was trying to leave and
apparently her friend started like
beating on her give her like a
concussion and like so it wasn't like it
just a little slap fight or anything
like that it was an actual physical
altercation and later actually Breanna
brought charges against like assault
charges but because she disappeared you
know three weeks later the charges were
dropped now initially after Brianna
Maitland disappeared they did
investigate this Kelli lacrosse person
because they said well you beat her up
three weeks ago so obviously you had
some kind of motive like to kill her I
guess but evidently that was she was
later dismissed as a suspect so they
don't think that that had anything to do
with it they just thought it was a very
unusual thing so fast forward to March
19th of 2004 Breanna has just taken her
GED exam and she passed and everything
like that so her and her mom they go out
to lunch to celebrate her getting her
GED her dad was out of state at the time
he worked a lot you know he traveled a
lot for work and stuff like that now her
mom said that you know nothing seemed
unusual she was very happy that she
passed her GED she was talking about
going to college and all this other kind
of stuff so after lunch
her and her mom they're going shopping
they're running errands are running
around and everything now there was also
a very weird thing that happened on this
particular day evidently according to
Brianna's mom she says we're in a store
were in the checkout line like we need
to check out and Breanna looks out the
window of the store and sees something
out there that appeared to catch her
attention
and she says to her mom she's like I
gotta go outside for a minute I'll be
back in a second so she goes outside and
then so her mom like you know buys her
stuff and then she waits and Breanna
comes back in or actually she meets
Breanna in the parking lot and she said
Breanna seemed very um agitated like she
was acting really strange like something
bad had happened and then she says she
but she wouldn't say what was going on
in her mom's like I don't really like to
pry like into her life or anything like
that so I was just kind of like okay
a little odd whatever so then she says
Brianna says to her mom she's like okay
well I got to get home cuz I gotta go to
work tonight she worked at a restaurant
called the Black Lantern in in
Montgomery Vermont so she's like I get
home and get ready to go to work you
know I got a shift tonight so she so the
mom drops Brianna off at her friend's
house where she was staying between
about 3:30 and 4:00 in the afternoon and
this is the last time that she was seen
at least by her mother now she did
Brianna did go to work and she worked
her regular shift she got off about 1120
1130 um she specifically said to her
co-worker she's like yeah I gotta go
home and rest I have she had a second
job also and she's like I gotta get up
early and go to my other job tomorrow
so she gets in her car and then
disappears
now the next afternoon somebody see
somebody complains that there's this
there's a house that's called the old
Dutch burn house and I believe it was
abandoned and somebody had driven by and
seen a car that had like backed into the
house like and busted the wall out and
apparently the headlights were on one
witness said the blinker was on so the
cops go out to check it out
and they find that this car is actually
registered to Brianna's mother but this
is the car that it's an ultimate valence
to the car that Brianna has been driving
to and from work they actually found two
of Brianna's paychecks in the front seat
- yeah uncashed Wow
outside of the car they found like an
empty water bottle they found a non
smoke cigarette they found some loose
change since they since Brianna had not
at this point been reported missing
because nobody knew she'd been missing
like I said she wasn't living with her
parents and her friends you know they
they gave a [ __ ] about her but she was
moving from house to house and you know
what I mean and she had several jobs so
they didn't like initially worried about
it so and also the girl that she had
been living with was away over the
weekend so I guess Brianna had left her
a note hey I'm going to work blah blah
blah but it's like the the friend didn't
see it until she came back on Monday
so I believe it was like five days
before Breanna was was reported missing
and it's weird because because she
hadn't been reported missing since the
car being found abandoned they I mean
the police they didn't know like I said
because she hadn't been reported missing
so they just thought oh well some drunk
driver backed into the building and then
took off because they were afraid of
getting in trouble so they just had the
car towed and they didn't really think
anything else about it so it was
actually several days before Brianna's
mom even knew that her car had been
found you know it means it was a long
time before it was like hooked up so
then it's you know a couple days later
and then her mom starts like calling
around and LexA would say there was no
body no did they check the house yeah
now the whole area was checked like I
said this was an abandoned house it's
been it's it's actually not there
anymore it burned down a couple years
ago yeah but yeah it's just this is just
such a weird and like I said this is
very much like the more on Marie case
because that was the whole thing where
she'd wonder like crash was no blood
snowbank I wonder if the car was in it
was it in gear was it in reverse when
they found her it was in a neutral or
park or they didn't man I'm not sure
actually because you know was it a
situation where it was left in reverse
she jumped out it was in there maybe
like ice it was going fast enough to
bust the wall out of this house which I
think was made of wood it looked like
because if it was put back into drive
than you know she was in it yeah or
somebody was in it yeah it's just I
don't know it's just really weird but
like so the mom like sees the picture of
the car because now they've like figured
out okay this car belongs to this girl
and you know she's like hey I haven't
seen her or heard from her and like I
said some witnesses like after it was
reported that this car belongs to this
girl like a bunch of people came forward
and said yeah I drove past that car like
a couple people thought it was so weird
that they'd like taking a picture of it
so that's how odd it looked yeah you
know I mean like it's one person's that
the headlights wrong this is a sign of
struggle that's what I mean and I think
like I said if I'm gonna say at first
just like in the earlier case I was
talking about at first like police were
like oh maybe
an accent or drunk-driving maybe she's
like accidentally back to sign of a
struggle but the more they look into it
they're like this looks like a play like
an abduction and Brianna's parents
believe the same thing they're like she
wouldn't have left the car like that
it's like there was no sign of struggle
inside the car but all her stuff was
still in there there was stuff like
outside of the cars though somebody had
like pulled her out maybe you know it
was like trying to get away from
somebody that's what I'm saying she was
backing up trying to get away lost
control the car hit that hit the house
yeah got converged on her jumped out of
his car great I feel like somebody
probably pulled her out of the car
because they were during his car like I
said you won't find any other tracks or
anything didn't mention it like I said
all her stuff is neon they need me at
these scenes was still in there her
debit card was still in the car her all
her medications were still in the car
contact lens thing was still in the car
for the audience you know I you know I
[ __ ] around a lot you know asking these
questions and talking [ __ ] chances are
the cops did do all this well of course
they just it's just not in the data that
we have available to us well yeah
sometimes here's the thing and
especially I leave things out of these
cases so they could they try to keep it
prime yeah and especially on a case like
this where I'm just trying to do like a
summary of like some of these
missing-persons cases because some of
these cases obviously there's tons and
tons more detail that I don't really
have time to get into I guarantee you
there's classified evidence well yeah II
won't release stuff aside right like I
said they're not idiots they do this as
a job yes they screw up yes they do dumb
things sometimes but you know they get
in part of the story we think of it than
they thought of me and I'm sure they
thought of some [ __ ] that we didn't
think of because that's what their job
is yeah and what did what their
publishing is only part of the story
exact more to it than it and like I said
I try to get like two or three different
sources I try to read through two or
three different sources on there you
know some of its contradictory some of
its and like I said sometimes you come
up with something that I'm like oh well
I might have seen that mention but I
don't remember or somebody didn't
mention it or I don't know yeah it's
real tough when you don't have the exact
release file
at hand they won't let you see those
yeah yeah now what they're what they're
thinking at this point because at this
point the FBI is involved in this case
they are treating this like foul play or
like a kidnapping abduction murder
they're presuming and they think that
the accident scene quote-unquote was
perhaps staged so that's the that's kind
of what they're leaning toward I'm gonna
say this I'm gonna say she was abducted
I kind of feel like that and she saw
that person out in that parked a lot
before it happened and I mean that's
that's why she was upset and the mom was
talking there was some maybe somebody
was stalking her yeah it was somebody
she knew and yes I mean she was breaking
up with him or her yeah I mean this
might be some lesbian action you don't
know what the hell's going on or like I
said it's like you know it happens a lot
because you know in a lot of those
gruesome murders I [ __ ] read about was
some lesbians fighting over a straight
girl that they were messing with and
this is in this girl was this is a high
school girls and they put that girl in
the truck for car and set her on fire
one of one of the worst cases so some of
this bad stuff that happens to these
girls there isn't always guys doing it
although 99.999 can't take it for
granted sometimes it's a girl
women can be horrible too it's just much
much less likely one woman who survived
a carjacking you know by a couple of
people and it was a guy and a girl and
she said it was the girl that scared her
the most that did the worst stuff to her
yeah you know cut her throat
no but she lived anyway but she wouldn't
she wasn't afraid of the guy she was
afraid of the girl I feel like what when
evil [ __ ] happens it's almost kind of
like I know this is like a weird thing
to say but when evil [ __ ] happens it's
like it's almost it's less surprising
when it's a dude I think it's rarer when
it's a woman but when it is a woman
she's way real bad yeah but it doesn't
happen that often it's just one in a
million
just like that weird a sadistic British
couple want that dude yeah but some of
the group with some of the women that
survived that said that they were more
afraid of the woman yeah yeah we're
gonna is that the Fred and rosemary yeah
we're actually gonna do a pro tip when
we do our Valentine's Day show because
our killer couples one that we did last
Valentine's Day was so popular that I
thought well I'm gonna do another one
this Valentine's Day so look for that
everywhere but I'm gonna do British
edition so we're gonna do Fred and
rosemary West I'm gonna do the Moors
Murders it'll be super fun yeah woman
could be a jealous [ __ ] man I can cruel
to another woman yeah that's what I said
it's rarer right but when it does happen
yeah just like that woman who was
torturing her daughters remember they
found the dead but they found the dead
body the one daughter had a bullet
removed from her to set her on fire they
had a whole program on her I remember
her name well look at that one that like
if you guys saw if you guys saw the
movie the girl next door that was based
on the Jack ketchum novel that was like
and that was like a fictionalized the
the novel was fictionalized the movie
was fictionalized but that was based on
a real case and that was some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] and that was a [ __ ] man you can
get some crazy-ass women out there like
I said well I kind of feel like like I
said when when a dude does something
[ __ ] up I'm just like yeah par for the
kind of Barbara Cardwell that well you
know not to be I'm not being sexist or
nothing like that it's just it's a lot
more likely what to do it surprises me
less the people that go out and start
killing women for sexual purposes tend
to be men yeah because there's a lot of
heterosexual men out there yeah but just
what's weird is that when they do [ __ ]
it's pretty standard usually strangling
somebody after they rape them that's the
mean that's usually with yeah raped and
strangled or stabbed that's most of it
okay but what's weird was when a woman's
involved it's usually something really
[ __ ] weird yeah because we we think
of more fucked-up [ __ ] we just don't
worry less likely to do it but when they
do do it but [ __ ] weird our brains
are a lot more twisted than men's are we
just we just don't usually do it that's
all and then some of the stuff that
involves a lot of cruelty is man-on-man
violence in those homosexual killers you
know I mean they do weird stuff too one
of those are messed up do you yeah yeah
like I said we did the show about the
family murders in Australia like
crap he was go back and watch that show
that was like and I write about true
crime and that one I was just kind of
like yeah no I'm not so yeah they're
like leather daddies evil versions of
leather daddies like operations so yeah
so with some big to-do yeah killing
[ __ ] like a big to-do I mean
lot of these straight guys engine I'll
just show ger well yeah they just one
and done yeah but yeah like he said yeah
like you said it's like there's kind of
a fetishistic they want to finish this
production right these are all sorry
bastards there but yeah so okay so the
the Brianna Maitland case about a week
after she went missing somebody called
in an anonymous tip and they said that
there's these two drug dealers from New
York called Ramon Ryan's and Nathaniel
Jackson and they kidnapped her and
they're holding her in a house in
Berkshire Vermont
now they police did actually go check
out this lead they did find these two
guys in this particular house where the
tipster said they were but they did not
find any sign that Briana had ever been
there however they did arrest them on
drug charges cuz they did find a bunch
of drug paraphernalia in the home cuz
they were obviously drug dealers but
they didn't find anything relating to
Brianna Maitland disappearance so they
think maybe that she knew them but there
is no evidence that they had anything to
do with her going missing although
someone did call in that tip so there
have been like other kind of similar
tips over the years of like anonymous
you know people calling in and saying
you know she's being held here she got
murdered there was actually one in 2004
that said the same thing that these two
guys had taken her but they said but
this person who was a woman said that
actually they murdered her and cut her
up and then fed her to pigs so I don't
know how accurate that is but that was
one anonymous tip that they got so these
two guys names keep coming up these two
draw
dealer's names but like I said their
house has been searched they were
arrested on other drug charges and they
didn't find any evidence that Briana had
been there but their names do keep
coming up in the in the anonymous
tipster people they keep calling in so
I'm just saying I don't know if they
have anything to do with it or not but
you know there have been other tips too
like somebody called in said oh she got
tied to a tree some said she's got you
know murdered and dumped in a lake and
stuff like that so at this point they
have no idea where she's been and it's
been you know such a long time it's been
since 2003 so again this is usually
linked to the more amuri case which only
happened about 90 miles away in very
similar circumstance it's like I said
more amore kind of like crashed her car
into a you know snowdrift and then like
kind of either wandered off or was
abducted and they never found her
afterward so but they don't think that
there's any link between the two
although they seem kind of similar to me
so I don't know how I don't know about
that but yeah so I think we're kind of
coming up to the end of the show that's
good show though it was like this kind
of stuff like I said it's really
disturbing yeah but for some reason I'm
just really fascinated with disturbing
things I could read all this all day
he's like it's funny because Tom will
not let me watch true crime stuff in the
in the room cuz I mean I could watch it
for a little while and then he's like
turn this [ __ ] off it's like it is but
for some reason it bothers me but not
I'll I know what I mean I like more of
the paranormal stuff yeah like more of
the conspiracy theory type so yeah
getting requests for conspiracy - yeah
we're gonna do more of that people yeah
there's a there's a lot of true crime is
interesting but I can't take a whole lot
of it yeah especially I can't why
because I look at it I go man this just
sucking nasty and it's like you're like
looking at the worst of humanity yeah
for long periods I don't know why it
does it like I said you look at that too
long you're gonna kind of gonna start to
think that's normal and most people
aren't like that this is a small
percentage of people but what you focus
on becomes your reality you look at it
too long you start worrying about it I
don't like it
see I don't think I don't have that
problem though because like I said I
write about these cases so sometimes I
will spend 12 hours a day like immersed
in this type of stuff you're sick you
know you crazy I am kind of and like I
said it bothers me like I read it I'm
just like man that's [ __ ] up but I'm
also like a really logical like
statistically minded person so I know
that this is very very rare it's like
the only reason that I'm reading about
so many cases is because I'm focusing on
that I know it's not that kind I like
warfare and combat you know America you
got Vikings fighting each other Roman
gladiators to me that's all fair you
know I mean that's man-on-man you you've
put yourself into this this is the game
that you want to play I don't see that
as cruelty or anything I don't see any
of those guys as yes as long as you're
not going above and beyond and like
doing [ __ ] exactly exactly you know
and none of these guys are innocent
there isn't any victims there these are
all bad [ __ ] doing what a bad
[ __ ] do yeah but when you have
these guys taking a totally innocent
person and putting them through hell and
killing them like they're garbage
I don't like I get very disturbed by
that mix I won't tell a [ __ ]
what I see that I do - yeah I just see
those instincts in me come out they go
I'm gonna eat you I started going
Hannibal Lecter I hate you so much for
doing that I'm gonna have to eat you
what I figured well I you understand
these primitive it makes me understand
these primitive tribesmen put the [ __ ]
that they do like I'm gonna kill him I'm
gonna go to that of the tribe and I'm
getting that dude i'ma cut his head off
I'm a shrink and I'm gonna eat him this
is hate like a lot of times like a lot
of these cases I read about I was like
oh if I met this dude and I did he was
the dude that did that modern education
is gonna tell you to kind of reject hate
be like Gandhi did not okay well they're
saying that for certain for a certain
some people are worthy of its not yeah
some people you do [ __ ] like that yeah
you have you have a roped humanity
exactly now we have these legal systems
that say no no no let the law handle
this don't get involved in this and it's
good because I don't want to be involved
in it yeah because you put me in a
position where I
to bring justice on a guy who's done
this horrible [ __ ]
it's Gangrel be pretty and I think that
people would probably agree with ya
it'll be pretty nice what I because I
don't think locking a person up like
that is justice I don't
and a guy alive certain grub you know
right threshold right I don't really
think you deserve to be treated right
I'm glad that I'm if you know what
you're doing yes like I said like that
dude that did the family murders like
that like you know all these serial
killers and stuff like that that just
like torture people and [ __ ] like that
it's like obviously if you know what
you're doing and you know that what
you're doing is bad and you're doing it
anyway and you're just making innocent
people suffer then I don't think you
should be given I saw I saw a thing of
some Chinese people skin and dogs alive
all right in a fur factory and letting
that dog walk around without its skin in
suffering because they were gonna eat at
me and I had the urge to kill them
Chinese people well how the hell can you
do that to a dog look I was kind of
gotten this moral conundrum you know the
man like what I do was there so I'm not
gonna be like a self-righteous about it
but you kid as long as they don't suffer
yes
don't I grew up hunting I've killed many
deer yeah all those deer were killed
instantly with rifle shot with respect
and I ate every bit of those deer it's
like I don't just like the Native
American you respect the deer spirit
giving me life I give Him glory
suffering exactly I don't torture
nothing yeah there's no reason for that
it's like why no that's just never
there's never an excuse me it's not
inhumane it's inhuman that's what I mean
true human yeah exactly
you've revoked you you are worse you are
officially worse than an animal
yeah Oh animals are good because animals
we have that hand holes are very good
well I gotta say no maybe a couple
animals play with things until they died
they don't know that they're tortured
like you know that's maybe they don't
really know later really no baby cookie
does that yeah she's a flame with the
lizards and until the lizard to save the
lizard she's actually rather gentle yeah
yeah it's not doing it
get him I if I get her early the lizards
are unharmed yeah it's just that it's
just annoying them she's just like kind
of she'll put him in her mouth she won't
even break the skin yeah she just likes
carrying him around and showing up but
eventually that eventually that kills
him so you can eventually she is she
kind of seen killer whales and actually
you know the things that I've seen those
chimpanzees bitin the other chimpanzees
nuts off in those fights and I mean it's
torture yeah
dolphins are also rapists yeah I hate to
tell you all you people seems like to
hire the animal the more chances are
that they're gonna have hatred I mean
tear things apart and on purpose yeah
punish them but there's just certain
things too where it's different when
it's chimpanzees fighting over territory
and fighting over then then somebody
just taken an innocent animal or an
innocent person and torturing to death
for pleasure yeah that's just and I
think I mentioned that on one of our
other shows where we were talking about
the court and cat killer which actually
they figured it's not a person now but
as a bunch of foxes but I even said it's
a fox doing it yeah but like I would I'm
kinda like that makes me feel better
like it's still kitties and that makes
me sad but like you know it's a fox he
doesn't know he's just trying to eat so
yeah exactly so I'm not gonna get upset
about that Fox are not bad creatures all
right they're very friendly though
thanks but I think I said on that show
that it's like you know much less
obviously if somebody did something to
you or did somebody who did something to
somebody my family yeah I'd be making a
stew out of their asses I'm like [ __ ]
even on that show I said if anybody did
anything to our kitty I would pull I
would put my hands up your ass and turn
you inside I'll find out oh my god it
was it was like that movie Society for
that dude Eve like put his fist up
somebody's ass like that and actually I
thought of that metaphor before it even
sees that movie but I was like that's
yes that's exactly what I would do to
them yeah yeah all right so we've got to
the end of the show so hopefully you
guys enjoyed it and you know should go
without saying but if you happen to know
anything about any of these missing
people please contact the respective
authorities in each case
and I guess that'll do it for episode
120 remember if you like the show to
like share subscribe and out of your
social media and share with all your
friends and family if you would like to
financially support the show we would
appreciate it very much you could go to
our patreon page which is patreon.com
slash 13 o'clock podcast or you can go
to our blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
WordPress com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation also go
check out our Zazzle store which is
zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock I just added
a whole bunch of new logo products on
there and I'm gonna be adding some new
t-shirts hopefully in the next few
months whenever I get time to design
some there's a new mason jar in there so
you can be just like Tom with a 13
o'clock darn you can put a Tom's gotta
be like Tom because I want mom we
haven't ordered one yet we just made
them yeah I just I only just made them
but yeah so go check that out if you
haven't also go check out our last
matinee which was episode 8 I think it
was and then our last movie
retrospective which was the classic
Blade Runner and that will do it for
this latest installment we will see you
next time bye
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]